IOWA MOMENTS AWAY.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
THE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL CONTINUES.
THE PRESIDENT, BY THE WAY,
SPEAKING TONIGHT IN A RALLY IN
THE STATE OF IOWA.
THE CAUCUS THEY ARE, THE FIRST
CONTENTS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATING PROCESS STARTS IN
JUST A FEW DAYS.
THAT’LL BE INTERESTING.
OF COURSE, WE’LL BRING YOU
HIGHLIGHTS OF THAT AS WE ALWAYS
DO.
THE LAST WEEK, WE’VE BEEN
WATCHING ALL THIS AND THE MOST
CYNICAL AMONG US HAVE DISMISSED
THE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL AS A
HOLLOW POLITICAL STUNT.
IT’S SOMETHING LIKE A NETWORK
AND INTIMATE DIVISION MUST’VE
COOKED UP THE, THEY SAY.
IT’S A BAD REALITY SHOW.
BUT WE ARE TRADITIONALISTSES
HERE SO WE RESISTED THAT HERE.
WHAT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT HERE
AND WHAT WE SAID IS IT’S ABOUT
FOREIGN POLICY.
IT’S ABOUT UKRAINE, THAT NOBLE
EASTERN EUROPEAN NATION THAT’S
THE SINGLE GREATEST ALLY IN THE
WORLD, OUR ONLY REAL ALLY.
IF UKRAINE WANTS IT, WE PROVIDE
IT.
THAT’S THE RULE, AS THEY’VE
EXPLAINED IN THE SENATE.
ALL DECENT AMERICANS STAND WITH
UKRAINE.
THE PRESIDENT SEEMED TO FALTER
IN HIS MORAL DUTY TO STAND WITH
UKRAINE, AND FOR THAT HE’S BEING
IMPEACHED.
SO IMPEACHMENT IS A VERY SERIOUS
THING.
UKRAINE DEPENDS ON IT BUT THAT
WAS OUR CONCLUSION YESTERDAY.
BUT MINE
MINDS CHANGE.
WE SAW THIS.
THIS IS AN EXCHANGE BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT’S LAWYER, EMINENT
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALAN
DERSHOWITZ AND SENATOR GOLDBERG
OF NEW JERSEY AND SENATOR BEHAR
OF NEW YORK.
WE DO NOT WANT TO BELITTLE THE
PROCESS HERE BUT WHAT YOU SEE IS
A SHADE THEATRICAL FOR SOMETHING
AS SERIOUS AS AN IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL, BUT JUDGE FOR YOURSELF.
>> ACCORDING TO WHAT I’M
READING, YOU ARE THE ONLY
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR WHO GOES
WITH THAT LINE.
THERE’S NOT ONE OTHER WHO AGREES
WITH YOU.
>> LET ME BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
IN 1867 AT COLUMBIA LAW
SCHOOL...
[LAUGHTER]
>> LISTEN, I NEED THE JUDGE TO
MOVE ON.
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING NOW YOU NEED
A CRIME?
>> YOU WILL NOT GET ME TO MOVE
ON UNTIL I MAKE THIS POINT.
>> HERE’S THE THING, ALAN, YOU
AREN’T GOING TO GET ANY TIME
BECAUSE YOU’VE GOT FOUR PEOPLE
ASKING YOU QUESTIONS.
>> Martha: WAIT, HOW DID
SENATOR GOLDBERG WIND UP ON
CUSTOMER COLUMBIA SAILING THE
OCEAN BLUE?
COLUMBUS NEVER EVEN WENT TO
UKRAINE, SO FAR AS WE KNOW.
AND SHE ATTACKED ABRAHAM LINCOLN
WHO ALSO NEVER WENT TO UKRAINE.
WE’D SEEM TO LOST THE THREAD
HERE FOR THE REASONING WAS
GETTING HARD TO FOLLOW.
IN THIS ROLLING BOUILLABAISSE OF
CONFUSION, A LAWMAKER FAMOUS FOR
THE WINDOW PAIN CLARITY OF
DEBATE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS VERY
QUICKLY.
JUST FOR GIGGLES.
WHAT IF THE PRESIDENT SPENT A
YEAR VACATIONING IN MOSCOW,
CHANGE THE LANGUAGE OF THIS
COUNTRY PERHAPS TO RUSSIAN, OR
DECIDED TO STOP DOING HIS JOB
ENTIRELY AND PERHAPS GOLF ALL
DAY?
ARE YOU SAYING WE HAVE NO
GROUNDS TO IMPEACH HIM?
BECAUSE THAT IS A CRIME EITHER.
>> Martha: THE LIST OF
THE>> Tucker: THE LIST GREW
LONGER IT NOT ONLY DID
DONALD TRUMP ASKED UNAUTHORIZED
QUESTIONS OF HOW HUNDRED BIDEN
MAKES A LIVING, AND THAT’S NOT
ALLOWED, HE’S ALSO APPARENTLY
LIVING IN PUTIN’S RUSSIA AND
PLANNING ON SWITCHING OUR
NATIONS ALPHABET TO ACRYLIC.
SOME OF THEM ARE NOT EVEN REAL
LETTERS, THEY LOOK ASTROLOGICAL
SIGNS.
HERE’S HOW THE HEARING ENDED
WITH A HIGH-STAKES WAGER.
>> Tucker: THE GAO SAID LAST
WEEK THAT WITHHOLDING THE AIDE
TO UKRAINE WAS ILLEGAL.
>> NO.
>> IT’S A CRIME.
>> ...
>> YES, THEY DID!
THEY SAID IT, THEY DID.
>> LET’S BET $1,000 TO BE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE PEACE OF
ISRAEL --
>> LET’S HYPOTHETICALLY SAY
>> Tucker: APPARENTLY THERE IS
SOME SORT OF UNFORTUNATE MIXUP
AND SOME OF THE VIDEO YOU JUST
SAW -- YES, ALL THE VIDEO ARE
PRODUCERS ARE SAYING, WAS NOT IN
FACT FROM TODAY’S SENATE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
THOSE ARE NOT ACTUALLY U.S.
SENATORS.
THEY EASILY COULD BE.
THEY ARE INSTEAD HOSTS ON A
DAYTIME CHAT SHOW OVER AT ABC
CALLED "THE VIEW."
THEY DESPISE THE PRESIDENT,
SINCERE ABOUT THAT.
LIKE MANY PEOPLE RUNNING AND
COMMENTING ON THE IMPEACHMENT
TRIAL, THEY SEEM TO HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT IT’S ACTUALLY ABOUT.
THEY DO NOT UNDERSTAND THE
CHARGES, NO NOTHING ABOUT THE
HISTORICAL PRECEDENT, FACTS AND
DETAILS ARE IRRELEVANT TO THEM.
THEY DIDN’T EVEN BOTHER TO READ
THE GAO REPORT THEY INTRODUCED
AS EVIDENCE, THEY GOT IT
BACKWARD BUT NOT IT SLOWED THEM
DOWN OR EVER DOES, THEY ARE LAZY
AND SILLY AND WRONG.
AT THE SAME TIME, THEY ARE
UTTERLY CERTAIN THEY ARE ON THE
MORALLY CORRECT SIDE OF HISTORY.
THEY KNOW THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE,
EXCELLENT PEOPLE ACTUALLY.
UNLIKE THAT HORRIBLE OLD RUSSIAN
MAN WHO SPEAKS RUSSIAN AND THE
RUBES WHO VOTED FOR HIM.
IN THEIR VIEW, THEY’VE GOT THE
BIG THINGS TOTALLY RIGHT AND
THAT’S ALL THAT MATTERS.
AND SO IN THAT WAY, DESPITE THE